thomas muster dem heft waits
yes
thomas doesn't work out for self the
bodybuilding competitions ray pause are
flex on stage for the dutchess
thomas massa impressive will also be so
teacher timme dating back out to the
jump the times a bit straight can
so if so so  slowly back strength forward
so Krems and then slowly shows he is
training seem a bit different
but many governments do it wrong the
training for a status in your
life so even the highest point
higher is not possible so as I said i
can do everything about the training and
everyday life  really comes after that it
takes a back seat so that means relationship
or or work that actually
everything comes at the back someone has already
complained I'm sure
there will be one or two peaks
coming on one side that you're only
exponents during training  etc but
this may get engaged ex friend
but then I had to change it a bit
to right here  getting such a nice
contraction results i
see myself on the beach because they look like they are
practicing a little so as i
said here it should be like pushing your
left arm right in now to
tighten the chest
muscles makes it
particularly good we will do it now  must had
trained and a bit of biceps
then you would hold the pose optimally
then you can see quite well the
shoulder muscles currently have the largest
I want it without you that we
now always stay one yes position
looks good by knitting obtained
by turning a bit
look a little friendly
million people in germany has jim
membership man happy with the bodies
if you now look in the mirror how
how do you feel about yourself i now see myself
as very muscular i the construction
sites everywhere almost everywhere chest
is more about the functions is more
about the neck  goes more legs went to me but
you can already see that the others don't
notice it that much  men would like to be what that's
actually already too much
yes yes yes that is yes that is subjective
what everyone else thinks of but you
see yourself much much thinner than you
see me that's how I see I see myself
much
thinner definitely that  is a classic
bodybuilder film star
somewhere also a perception
disorder yes if i came back from kalli
training then there would
still be vendors and so
on she says i'm
almost satisfied with the one with the
definition that's how
marseille place at germany's should be  next
topmodel championships i would like to
do sport all my life and
not just want to live to be 40 years
old just because i take some kind of
preparations to generate a certain
growth in the muscles
i don't think anyone has any of that
and sees what sees but also  everyone is
different
the ideal basically always grows with people who
take things like that it also says at k  m on
the forehead I take it from ruin
very few admit it and that's
exactly the problem that's why there
's the association that only says
we only do natural we test that we
test that shoot often and we test
that also has in competition and  I think
that's good that's why I'm also in the
association because then it's also a fair
fair sport what do you like about it
thomas hess from whole
morning post pix from the competition are sean
hayes instagram so what do you like for
example the picture for example from the
competition okay that  pumping up just
before the stage I think that's actually
quite
okay I think that's quite good but that's the way it is
now, I mean, for example,
something like that I find more attractive now,
yes, your point of view is subjective,
everyone sees it differently and there, as I
said, well  So I didn't find the definition
to be that ideal, but in terms of
style, it fits that it was really
uploaded
late to the news.
Thomas is the di  nge took photos in the
election campaign in the logbook midfielder
freezing also on
instagram eg the attention
what do you like about it a good feeling when
people if they like
what you have also post leipzig it's okay
that feels good what you
have to do for it  what you have to
do without approach or how
do i go to sport
i cancel the party because i
prefer to sleep a few hours that's
just a lot that depends on it and
that's because most people don't and
through, for example, they
somehow know it  way to appreciate it
makes you happy
how about thomas krenn the
car is at the arenas dirrell kraus
always finds something to complain about
he doesn’t make any compromises so
he says no to all drinks
that maybe he would like to have but
no those  would somehow
throw you back or go out late in the evening
then the lack of sleep then the
muscles can ni  the youngsters
regenerate until the next training session
goes home
so if he had
lost his character now, his
humorous manner and all that
humanness that makes him
special then i would have been
worried or if it would go in the direction of anorexia or something like that then it would be
that's really so worrying
but it's not just a few
weeks before he with marinen thomas the
lost the motto breast cancer even want
your sex cam to thomas competitions to
pull
the father of the kind of five years ago
the valves somehow pressed
info what kind of feelings I had to deal
with that was the sport for
a good imst in a suitcase the
problem comes to the last sport in front of the
door and if everything goes well
leave it standing when you leave the
sport again that would be optimal and  i did that
five times a week
thomas monz back level fashion system
arias from america professional subcutaneous fat wt
ebe and that's why i
've just
noticed that i've already noticed veronika citizen eco
substance found in the body by some
people from so injected winkels why
are you even doing this now you're
only then i hear quite often that i
look pretty old
so around 30 early 30s  I was also
already appreciated and
by squinting my eyes during the
training when you are very
strenuous in any case
to recognize early wrinkling
that doesn't bother me yet I want to
prevent
are bloody anyway we medium steak
apropos who is something and if you aren't
pores we will
tease very well thomas ist peking before the extreme
bodybuilding championships coming up in
november
the timing of the top five in hesse
but to get no mass definition he
wants the state of work and sacrifice
sfm do you think you will be able to handle
it if you  in front of the mirror
guess and the moment comes ok now the
physical area alright well that's the
way it is e  it's a matter of
processes that means you need to
get older with every year of training
you learn new things and i
think i'll be able to deal with it
now i could also imagine being 80
because i'm not in the mood for it
then probably  just as little and
that's the thing that keeps coming over the years
i think and then you have to get used to
it but the content of life you have now
it just comes with the awareness
ok 100 i can't
reach
it now yes then later that's why i have to  now
stepping on the gas started 12 is a bit of
time
but i've worked out a good
lead and i want to
use that